nostalgia it's delicate but potent but
by don draper yup your favorite dose of
a 1960s cocktail of sex drugs and
advertising is coming to an end but as
AMC's madman begins its final season we
call to ask seriously why do we love it
so much I mean it's not like sexism and
white male privilege in the workplace or
infidelity at home exist anymore right
okay but regardless times have changed
since the 1960s and 70s era of Mad Men
Florida here's how they have and haven't
women in Mad Men generally have one
primary purpose to serve sure Peggy and
Joan are notable exceptions but
generally women in Mad Men serve as
office eye candy as errand runners and
of course side chicks why is it that
every time a man takes you out to lunch
around here you're due to dessert so how
else did it suck to be female in the Mad
Men era get this if you are a woman in
the 1960s you could not get a credit
card or serve on a jury you cannot go on
birth control attend an Ivy League
school and don't even think about equal
rights and privileges in the workplace
all right so we have made strides since
then but don't get too excited just yet
because American women have a long way
to go in the workplace women still earn
77 cents to a man's dollar even though
they make up more than half of the
workforce they make up less than 15% of
executive officers a little over eight
percent of top earners and less than
five percent of Fortune 500 CEOs working
mothers have it the worst since the u.s.
is the only country in the developed
world that doesn't guarantee paid
maternity leave all right get out now
who doesn't get a kick out of Roger and
Don's white male privilege attitudes but
still the lack of diversity in their
office is kind of hard to ignore women
are mostly relegated to secretarial
positions and the first black character
in the office is introduced only in the
fifth season
that's a little late and a little
inaccurate for many critics who say
there was actually a vibrant scene of
black designers and advertisers at the
time since the 1960's Americans of color
have made inroads in the workforce but
there's still a diversity problem when
it comes to managerial positions the
higher up you go the more it looks like
seasons one through four
in fact in 2015 there were only five
black CEOs and fortune 500 companies but
at least your boss isn't wearing
blackface at a Country Club hopefully
remember Xerox machines I don't the age
of Internet has radically changed how we
use communication in business in Mad Men
advertising was only available on TV on
billboards and in newspapers computers
they gave Ginsberg a complete mental
breakdown advertising today is of course
more than available in papers on TV and
on Billboard's but it still caters to
the Internet using hashtags and
referencing memes popular advertising
boils down to getting you to click share
whatever the case with what has and
hasn't changed since the days of the
Draper's the Olsson's and the Cooper's
Mad Men has given us a solid eight years
of debate on race sex and privilege and
eight years of this what you call love
was invented by guys like me